[Music]
an accidental leak that probably
happened on purpose a face that scared
his own daughter to tears celine
freaking dion stay tuned to find out
what you may not know about ryan
reynolds deadpool
for many people it's hard to separate
ryan reynolds and deadpool it doesn't
help that reynolds has made a career out
of playing fast-talking and quirky
comedic characters who could easily be
described as deadpool-esque while
reynolds undoubtedly has a good sense of
humor that's really where the comparison
ends his co-star brianna hildebrand told
enews there's a conception that he's a
lot like deadpool but he's just really
funny and a really big sweetheart
actually my favorite times on set were
when he brought his kids because he
became mushy dad and it was really cute
it's no secret that deadpool was in
production hell for the longest time
variety reported that rhett reese and
paul wernick had been working on the
script since 2010 but the timeline
actually goes all the way back to the
aftermath of blade trinity while that
production was marred with bizarre
stories and incidents it had one bright
spot it brought writer director david s
goyer and ryan reynolds together
according to ign goyer revealed that he
had loved working with reynolds he
newline cinema and marvel all wanted to
work with the actor again thanks to his
ability to be a funny credible action
star with some solid acting chops as
well goyer was set to co-write and
direct his version of deadpool but the
movie wouldn't have been allowed to
connect with weapon x or wolverine in
any way because the x-men belonged to
20th century fox at the time turns out
the rights issue ended up becoming a
bigger stumbling block than initially
expected all but scrapping goyer's plans
eventually fox brought reynolds into the
fold as deadpool casting him in 2009's
infamous x-men origins wolverine
there are dozens of iconic lines
scattered throughout deadpool
screenwriters rhett reese and paul
wernick received praise for their
outstanding script but it was absolutely
a collaborative effort the actors were
encouraged to improvise and come up with
their own lines as revealed in a cast
interview for dest hollywood ryan
reynolds confessed that he was happy to
see some of his improv make the final
cut especially one of the most famous
lines of the film which came after
deadpool arrived at an empty looking
x-mansion it's a big house it's funny
that i only ever see two of you it's
almost like
the studio couldn't afford another x-men
in a separate interview with yahoo reese
revealed that everyone cracked up
laughing when they heard it for the
first time and even former 20th century
fox chairman jim gianopoulos declared it
his favorite line from the film ryan
reynolds first rodeo as deadpool didn't
go according to plan while x-men origins
wolverine promised to dive deep into
logan's past including his history with
wade wilson the results were mixed to
say the least for some reason the merc
with a mouth was turned into weapon 11.
supposedly one of the most powerful
mutants around but one that couldn't
talk reynolds did what he could with
what he was given and most viewers at
the time agreed that he was an excellent
choice to play deadpool the actor
revealed that he actually shaped the
character in a more significant way than
expected telling gq it was during a
writer's strike so all my dialogue in
that movie i wrote i mean in the stage
directions it just said deadpool shows
up talks really fast and makes a lot of
jokes that said reynolds knew that there
would be fan backlash to how deadpool
turned out at the end of the film and
warned the studio about it alas his
pleas fell on deaf ears
not only was deadpool a triumph for ryan
reynolds but it was also a major success
for director tim miller while he had
been widely recognized for his
outstanding work in special effects and
animation the 2016 superhero movie
marked his live action directorial debut
as a result fans were excited to see
what miller and reynolds could cook up
for the sequel with a bigger budget and
greater financial support unfortunately
the dream team didn't return for the
sequel as miller made way for david
leach to take over directorial duties in
a later interview with kcrw miller
confirmed what everyone had long
suspected there was a fallout between
him and reynolds with miller saying it
became clear that ryan wanted to be in
control of the franchise you can work
that way as a director quite
successfully but i can't i don't mind
having a debate but if i can't win i
don't want to play
ryan reynolds is no stranger to comic
book franchises whether it was his guest
appearance on sabrina the teenage witch
or his starring role as nick walker in
ripd it's clear that the canadian actor
has a passion for these properties
however there's no doubt that deadpool
is the role that's closest to his heart
especially since it took so long to get
it right the back and forth between
reynolds and the studio throughout the
2000s and 2010s is a story that's worthy
of its own documentary as the actor
refused to give up on the film being
made
i know right
whose balls did i have to fondle to get
my very own movie there was a point
though when he decided to give them an
ultimatum as he revealed to gq right
before i took green lantern i wrote a
letter to my executive at fox saying i'm
gonna take this movie green lantern if
you guys aren't gonna make deadpool i'm
at the altar about to say i do to
somebody else but tell me you want to
spend the rest of your life with me
because i want to spend the rest of my
life with you the response he received
wasn't positive stating that there was
no intention to make the film so he went
on to make green lantern that movie
bombed so there was a second chance for
reynolds and fox to renew their vows
and please don't make the super suit
green
or animated
according to den of geek despite the
rumors of deadpool being in active
development for years the tipping point
for fans was when test footage leaked in
july 2014. suddenly the awful memories
of the character in x-men origins
wolverine were dead and buried as the
nearly two minutes of footage perfectly
encapsulated everything that the wacky
merc was all about in the comics while
there might have been a few calls for
the deadpool movie to be made before the
demand became overwhelming after the
footage dropped online it was never
revealed who actually leaked the footage
no one is ever likely to come forward
and admit it but reynolds has brought up
some possibilities my mom was like what
does this button do
i guess we're making the movie now he
gave an indication of who it could be to
test hollywood saying there has been a
lot of speculation about that and all i
can say is that it was one of the four
of us me rat reese tim miller or paul
wernick somebody did it once fox decided
to give the thumbs up to a deadpool
movie the pressure was on since the
budget was tight and the deadline's even
tighter as ryan reynolds revealed to
yahoo there were 10 months between the
first day of filming and the actual
release date with no time to lose
reynolds and tim miller knew they didn't
have long to get the suit right the
nerves dissipated when they finally saw
the suit for the first time with
reynolds saying we cried we just wept
miller added that when he saw reynolds
in costume he instantly knew that
everything was going to work and he
sobbed again
bret reese and paul wernick were on the
deadpool journey with ryan reynolds for
six years their patience was eventually
rewarded with the film entering
production and their game-changing
script being a foundation for the next
era of superhero movies since reece and
wernick had been part of the team from
the get-go reynolds wanted them on set
to provide their input and see the
fruits of their labor however reece
revealed on geeking out that fox didn't
want to cough up the extra cash to have
them present so reynolds paid out of his
own pocket to have his collaborators
around considering the
782.6 million dollars that deadpool made
at the box office the studio should have
certainly reimbursed the star for his
expenses later on
as a trained mercenary mr poole is an
expert at all sorts of combat whether it
be military grade or hand-to-hand
shenanigans the site of ryan reynolds
deadpool handling his katana swords
showcased his absolute commitment to the
cause as the actor revealed to the
national post he spent time with a
katana expert on both the x-men film and
deadpool to sharpen up his skills saying
i remember my first day the guy who was
training me looked a lot like a guy who
was going to make a necklace out of my
teeth that was sort of the gold standard
that was set from early on the training
certainly paid off some of the best
action scenes in the deadpool films are
a cut above the rest in the genre mostly
thanks to wade wilson's shiny blades
there's no denying that wade wilson's
mug caught everyone off guard the first
time they witnessed it you look like an
avocado had sex with an older more
disgusting avocado
makeup artist bill corso deserves all
the credit in the world for successfully
transforming ryan reynolds face in such
a convincing and unsettling way he even
managed to frighten the actor's young
daughter as reynolds told yahoo it just
made my daughter cry every time she came
to the set he added that the makeup
process would take up to four hours
every day and that the mask could get
uncomfortable but the discomfort was
ultimately worth it not just for the
results on screen but also because he
could peel off his face at the end of
the day and chuck it at the crew for a
good laugh
isn't it weird that ryan reynolds always
seems to have the red and black deadpool
suit nearby whenever he needs it there's
a reason for it as reynolds told yahoo
there was no way i was not gonna leave
with a suit reynolds was a producer on
the deadpool film so technically he does
have some claims on owning the suit
perhaps more importantly he's involved
in a bulk of the franchise's marketing
which often requires him to be dressed
in characters so it makes logical sense
for him to have the suit readily
available fox didn't seem to have a
problem with it either since he
practically became a brand ambassador in
exchange for a single costume
considering the deadpool movies have
made over a billion dollars for the
studio it was always unlikely that the
execs would complain too much about it
as much as deadpool is all about the
laughs and action on screen ryan
reynolds has used his influence as the
comic book character to make a
difference in other people's lives he
meets many children through the
make-a-wish foundation and leaves a
lasting impact as it turns out the
children do the same to reynolds as well
back in 2016 reynolds posted an
emotional tribute to young conor mcgarth
after the 13 year old died of cancer the
two had met through the foundation after
mcgarth made a wish to be the first
person to see deadpool and reynolds and
his team obliged with reynolds saying i
traveled up to edmonton alberta to
surprise him with a rough cut of the
film he added that even though the film
wasn't complete he quote never felt
luckier to get to be wade wilson as he
saw mcgarth's joy at watching the movie
considering how much time and energy
ryan reynolds has invested in the
deadpool franchise it's clear that many
people view him as the brains behind the
operation that said he's still working
with a studio and everyone knows that
the person who signs the checks is the
one who gets the final say well about
that as per the rap a new deal was
negotiated between reynolds and fox
after the success of the first film not
only did the actor receive a sizable pay
bump to return for the sequel but he
also secured creative control and
casting approval undoubtedly this also
explains why the rift between him and
tim miller was only going to go one way
in the end
when deadpool 2 was released many fans
wondered who played the role of
juggernaut since it certainly wasn't
vinnie jones under the metal helmet the
cgi in voice gave nothing away but it
was eventually revealed that ryan
reynolds pulled double duty on set and
lent his talents to bring charles
xavier's half-brother to life in this
wacky film we needed to give brian
another franchise so i'm just kidding
while it was a pleasant reveal for fans
it was also equally surprising for his
cast mates stefan kapisi the actor who
voiced colossus told the hollywood
reporter that he had no idea reynolds
was playing another character in the
film saying brian is always there when
i'm working on colossus helping me with
the lines and giving me ideas then i saw
ryan getting into the cgi costume and
i'm like what's going on man did i miss
something as soon as disney bought fox
fans wondered when deadpool would make
his arrival in the house of mouse many
expected him to show up in avengers end
game or a new marvel show on disney plus
but his first crossover with the mcu was
in a hilarious skit with korg when they
reacted to the free guy trailer however
ryan reynolds had a different pitch the
first time around suggesting a much
darker trajectory for the merc with the
mouth revealing to ign i wanted to do a
short film of deadpool interrogating the
hunter who killed bambi's mom but the
whole gist of it is that deadpool is
actually just a huge fan for obvious
reasons the disney exacts turned their
noses up at the idea since it would have
made deadpool a bigger villain than
thanos in an instant so reynolds went
back to the drawing board and pitched
them the deadpool korg video which was
much better received by the suits
in the comics deadpool loves bea arthur
and how could he not the deadpool film
decided to respect canon and paid
tribute to wade wilson's obsession with
arthur by having him wear a shirt
adorned with her photo according to gq
ryan reynolds paid twenty thousand
dollars to use arthur's likeness in the
film while the actor didn't confirm the
amount he said it was more a question of
talking to the estate and the family
personally and just reaching out and
saying we're gonna take care of this and
there was a little donation made to her
charity it was a nice touch because it's
clear to see that deadpool's razor-sharp
wit was directly influenced by dorothy's
bornex sarcastic charm
deadpool 2 had its fair share of
surprises such as alan tudyk and matt
damon as two self-referential
hillbillies but brad pitt's blank and
you missed appearance as vanisher was
the one that everyone was talking about
afterwards according to comicbook.com
pitt had actually been in consideration
to play cable before he was forced to
step aside due to scheduling conflicts
the question is how did the production
convince the academy award-winning actor
to make a cameo as one of the most
forgettable comic book characters in the
world
and then there's just this reveal right
at his death that it's actually brad
pitt
he just thought that was so funny and
because of that he was in that was all
down to ryan reynolds he explained to
entertainment tonight i was told all he
wants is a cup of coffee and i said like
a franchise or just one individual cup
of coffee and i was told one individual
cup of coffee which was really his way
of saying i'm doing it for nothing and
it was a total solid and the nicest
thing anyone could do was anyone truly
surprised when celine dion found her way
onto the deadpool 2 soundtrack and the
merc with the mouth performed a dance
routine in the ashes music video
director david leach told entertainment
weekly that he and music supervisor john
houlihan found the track ashes for the
movie but needed someone to record it
when he brought up the ballad to ryan
reynolds he only had one person in mind
a fellow canadian leech elaborated
saying and he's like you know who we
should get we should approach celine
she's an incredible singer she's amazing
but she's also someone who works in the
sort of subversive deadpool universe
fortunately when the team approached
dion she accepted since her son was a
deadpool fan and she loved the song of
course
ryan reynolds has been open about his
struggles with anxiety telling variety
that it's something he's suffered with
his whole life while making deadpool was
a passion project for him it also took
its toll on him mentally he confessed i
never ever slept or i was sleeping at a
perfect right angle just sitting
straight constantly working at the same
time reynolds admitted that he put
immense pressure on himself because of
the fans they'd waited so long for a
movie that he felt obligated to deliver
something that exceeded all their
expectations in a separate interview
with gq reynolds said that he
experienced somewhat of a nervous
breakdown after deadpool was finished
when he booked appointments to see
doctors they all told him that he was
suffering from anxiety ultimately
reynolds credited his wife with helping
him get through it and being by his side
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite anti-heroes are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]